اذا في التطورات ايضا تظاهرات تحدث او
حدثت في مشيغن تزامنا مع وصول الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن لهذه المدينه مظاهرات
مطالبه بوقف الحرب كما نشاهد في هذه الصور
للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الذي يجري هذا
اللقاء في
هذه المدينه عن هذه المظاهرات في هذه
المدينه وخصوصيتها وبعدها خاصه فيما ي لق
بالجاليه العربيه والمسلمه معنا من ولايه
ميشيغان مراسل الجزيره ناصر الحسين ناصر
ماذا عن
هذه المظاهرات قبل قليل كانت معنا بيسان
ابو كويك ايضا تحدثت عن التصريحات فيما
يتعلق ب فرض اوامر تنفيذيه فيما يتعلق
بالمستوطنين
وربطتها بمساله زيارته الى زياره الرئيس
الامريكي طبعا الى
مشيغن نعم بالفعل هنا العرب الامريكيون
والفلسطينيون الامريكيون بوجه خاص لا
يعتبرون هذا القرار للرئيس بايدن الذي
يعلنا عنه قبل ساعات بخصوص اربعه من
المستوطنين كافيا وكثيرون يعتقدون صراحه
انها لعبه انتخابيه في اطار هذه الحمله
الانتخابيه وراي في هذا المبنى بالفعل
الرئيس بايدن الان يتحدث الى ممثلي نقابات
العمال نقابات السيارات اتحاد عمال
السيارات المحلي في ولايه ديترويت
المعروفه بقطاع السيارات ولكن بطبيعه
الحال خيم على هذا اللقاء في هذا المبنى
الكثير من الغضب غضب الناخب في ميشيغن
وغضب الناخب العربي او المسلم في مشيغن
هذه ولايه متارجحه الرئيس الامريكي يحث
الان الناخبين الديمقراطيين في ميشيغن على
التصويت له هو يطلب ودهم ولكن حقيقه قبل
قليل فقط كانت لدينا هذه المظاهرات وترون
بقايا رجال الشرطه يمينا ويسارا حوالي 200
من الناخبين العرب الامريكيين الذين جاؤوا
امام المبنى وصحوا بطبيعه الحال انهم
يرفضون التصويت وهناك عرب امريكيون ناشطون
قبل اسابيع عده بداوا حمله لا تصوت لبايدن
وهذا كله وصل الى اسماع البيت الابيض ايضا
الاسبوع الماضي البيت الابيض الرئيس بايدن
بعث المسؤوله المسؤوله التي اختارها هو
بنفسه كي تتحدث الى زعماء وناشطي الجاليه
العربيه وتحاول اقناعهم بان موقف الرئيس
بايدن هو الموقف الصحيح من هذه الحرب على
الغزه ولكن الزعماء المحليون رفضوا حتى
اللقاء مع مبعوثي البيت الابيض اليوم ايضا
علمنا من الناشطين العرب والسياسيين
والزعماء المحليين انهم ايضا رفضوا لقاء
مقترحا لوزير الخارجيه تصوروا كان البيت
الابيض مستعدا لارسال بلينكن ليجلس مع
زعماء ووجوه هذه الجاريه العربيه والمسلمه
والفلسطينيه هنا وهي امريكيه ناقب لها دور
ولها صوت ورفضوا وبالتالي يمكن القول الان
بين بايدن والعرب في امريكا قطيعه شبه
كامله في هذه اللحظه والود الذي يخطبه
الرئيس بايدن لا يبدو انه يجد اي اذان
صاغيه لدى الجاليات العربيه في 2020 هذه
هي اهميه مشيغن هذه الولايات متارجحه رئيس
بايدن فاز ب14 ال صوت فقط مقابل ترامب لو
العرب هؤلاء ب 100000 صوت مثلا رفضوا
التصويت له او 150 الف رفضوا التصويت له
وهو عد وعددهم يبلغ اكثر من 350 الف
فبالفعل هناك خطوره على موقف الرئيس بايدن
ويقال في واشنطن ان رئيس بايدن مذعور
حقيقه من ان يخسر الرئاسه بسبب هذه الحرب
في غزه ولا يريد ان يفتح المجال لخصمه
ومنافسه ترامب وبالتالي المعركه
الانتخابيه بدات
واسعي وراء قلب وتصويت هذا الناخب العربي
بدات لكن الكثيرين هنا لا يصدقون البيت
الابيض بكل بساطه